freigabe für europa die eu lässt auch
den corona impfstoff der us-firma
moderner zu zitterpartie in georgia in
einer knappen stichwahl entscheidet sich
ob im us senat künftig die republikaner
oder die demokraten die weichen stellen
abschluss der vierschanzentournee karl
geiger wird zweiter den gesamtsieg
sichert sich der pole kamil stoch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am mittwochen
arbeitet lehmann ist auch dafür den
sport als standort von mir und wir
beginnen mit der nachricht des tages die
eu hat heute auch den amerikanischen
impfstoff moderner zugelassen
damit kommt neben dem von biotech weise
ein zweiter impfstoff auf den markt und
steht offenbar schon nächste woche zur
verfügung
dennoch wird hier weiter heftig
diskutiert warum die impfkampagne gegen
das groner virus so schleppend anläuft
christiane hübscher mit einzelheiten aus
dem kabinett
impfen ist chefsache wenn die
bundeskanzlerin nach der
kabinettssitzung die fachminister
zusammen holt altmaier braunen sparen
und scholz und es nur darum geht wie
kriegen wir schnell mehr impfstoff zu
den menschen
der gesundheitsminister hat kritisiert
seit tagen verteidigt sich grund für den
engpass für diese knappheit zu beginn
der impfkampagne sind übrigens nicht zu
wenig bestellte menge sondern grund für
die knappheit sind die fehlenden
produktionskapazitäten der
impfstoffhersteller biontech soll
deshalb im februar ein neues werk in
marburg eröffnen doch bis alle die
wollen versorgt sind wird es dauern
piontek hat in deutschland bisher gut
1,3 millionen dosen ausgeliefert
wöchentlich kommen 667.000 dazu bis
mitte februar soll es vier millionen
sein
dazu kommt nun der moderner impfstoff
das us amerikanische aktien wurde heute
von der eu zugelassen
doch auch davon kommen erst mal nur zwei
millionen dosen hier an
jetzt wird es mit den weiteren
zulassungen auch mehr impfstoffe geben
und das muss unsere hoffnung für das
ganze jahr sein dass wir schnell viele
impfstoffe gekommen und damit dann auch
die bevölkerung schützen können der
bayerische ministerpräsident tauscht
heute relativ geräuschlos seine
gesundheitsministerin aus melanie huml
war schon im sommer nach einer test
panne in die kritik geraten
auch söder hat heute offenbar mit dem
start der impfkampagne
was gestern ein positives signal war
dass die kanzlerin ist mit zur chefsache
gemacht hat so dass der insgesamt glaube
ich auch noch mal mehr
mehr motivation und auch mit zug
gehindert von angeblicher entmachtung
will jens spahn nichts hören er betont
heute sein gutes verhältnis zur
kanzlerin
wir vertrauen uns nicht nur unter stress
aber auch unter stress was man eben sagt
wenn man unter druck ist bis zum sommer
will spahn allen deutschen ein
impfangebot machen wir vertrauen und
sagt sparen also über sein verhältnis zu
bundeskanzlerin ist er damit jetzt aus
der schusslinie rostock unterlag energy
oder steht der gesundheitsminister
weiter unter druck
also der druck wird bleiben er kann sich
jetzt zwar die kritik mit den anderen in
dieser speziellen kabinettsrunde teilen
aber er wird sich ja auf jeden fall noch
um zwei dinge vorrangig kümmern müssen
das eine ist die transparenz in sachen
im strategie aber auch was die
organisation angeht denn das wird nötig
sein um die unsicherheit und die
unzufriedenheit mit dem langsamen
anlaufen des impfens einzudämmen
denn moderner wird zwar ein wenig luft
schaffen aber auch mit den dem moderne
impfstoffe das natürlich nicht gelingen
alle priorisierten auf einen schlag zu
impfen
der impfstoff bleibt zunächst ein
knappes gut damit muss man umgehen
und das zweite worum sich jens spahn
wird kümmern müssen das wirft schon
seine schatten voraus nach umfragen ist
nur ein drittel aller deutschen dazu
bereit momentan sich impfen zu lassen
wenn man dann wirklich die anvisierte
zahl der impfungen erreichen will da ist
noch viel überzeugungsarbeit nötig und
die wird sich in spa nicht ersparen
können danke für ihre einschätzung
schöpp unterlag impfen das ist der wohl
noch lange weg aus der krise
die aktuelle datenlage ist wegen der
feiertage noch immer nicht vollständig
zu überblicken
aber schauen wir auf die neuen zahlen
das robert-koch-institut zählte 21 1237
positive corona tests 2009 10 menschen
starben an oder mit cupid 19
mehr als 13 millionen impfdosen sind in
deutschland bereits verteilt knapp
370.000 menschen erhielten ihre erste
impfdosis das sind 0,44 prozent aller
deutschen relativ erfolgreich läuft die
impfkampagne in mecklenburg vorpommern
dort liegt die quote bei 1
einmal 12 prozent an yapi muss die dosis
für heute ausgegeben im impfzentrum des
landkreises rostock im flughafen laage
vier mobile teams hat der kreis im
einsatz
auch mehrere hundert freiwillige haben
sich dafür im nordosten gemeldet früher
wurden die alten und pflegeheime
kontaktiert einverständniserklärungen
besorgt gute voraussetzungen für das
team das heute im seniorenzentrum
kröpelin impft es ist schon finde ich
gut und sehr straff organisiert auch und
wir sind ja heute auch hier im
pflegeheim und ich finde dass ist gut
vorbereitet und die heime sind das erste
ziel
17.500 bewohner und 40.000 mitarbeiter
in strafe logistik kaum pannen beim
impfen bislang dazu schlanke
verwaltungen in großen landkreisen und
eine hohe impfbereitschaft der senioren
auch in kröpelin machen 90 prozent der
heimbewohner mit ich habe erst geworden
also ich hoffe dass wir im februar hier
normalität mehr einkriegen nach der
zweiten impfung vom personal lässt sich
hier wie in anderen heimen rund ein
drittel impfen
in den kliniken ist die mitarbeiter im
quote deutlich höher
jetzt hoffen alle auf mehr impfstoff ich
hab ihn zuversichtlich dass in
deutschland mit der zunahme der fünften
dosen das dann noch die impfbereitschaft
deutlich steigen wird
zehnmal so viele impfungen die bisher
könnten sie hier am tag eigentlich
schaffen
am freitag mit die nächste lieferung
erwartet die verlängerung des showdowns
stellt bislang kaum jemand in frage
dafür sind die aktuellen infizierten und
totenzahlen einfach zu hoch über eine
neue regel aber gibt es hitzige debatten
die einschränkungen der
bewegungsfreiheit auf einen radius von
15 kilometer in corona hotspots also in
gebieten mit einer 7 tages instanz von
über 200 infizierten je 100.000
einwohner in sachsen haben sie damit
bereits erfahrung an seinem stern
berichtet schön ruhig ist es hier
meistens jetzt ganz besonders corona
stille in bärenstein in sachsen hier
gilt schon vorüber deutschlandweit
gestritten wird die 15 kilometer riegel
zum teil zum kurzen sie kennen ja nicht
zweimal unternehmen im anti virus kampf
gebunden an den eigenen hotspot wohnort
wohnort heißt das heimatdorf oder die
heimatstadt also große unterschiede in
einer größeren stadt ist ein 15
kilometer radius ohne probleme
einzuhalten aber im ländlichen raum wo
es schon allein von vielen vielen dorf
und viel weiter ist um bis in die
kreisstadt zu kommen da ist es schwierig
und die menschen sind auch darüber
erbost im gespräch weil sie das als
nicht sinnhaft erachten sagt landrat
reinhard krebs in seinem land thüringen
ist die bewegungseinschränkung aktuell
eine empfehlung an die landkreise auch
andere bundesländer zögern
flickenteppich wieder denn der radius
beschluss müsste auch kontrolliert
werden und das ist aufwendig also so
dass wir als polizei zunächst mal eine
ganz normale allgemeine
verkehrskontrolle machen wie die
identität feststellen
und wenn wir einen verstoß dabei
überprüfen geben wir das weiter an die
ordnungsämter und die ordnungsämter
werden dann diese bußgeldbescheide an
den adressaten aus senden
die kritik an den gestern beschlossenen
maßnahmen ist heute groß von ärzten aber
auch zustimmung
die eingeleiteten maßnahmen halten wir
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt definitiv für
angemessen sie sind vorsichtig und sie
sind angemessen vorsichtig vor allen
dingen angesichts der tatsache dass wir
auch deutschland in situationen
unverändert eine hohe belastung haben
und um die sicherstellung der versorgung
von erkrankten aller erkranken in
deutschland zu gewährleisten ist das
jetzt sehr wichtig denn dazu gehört auch
spätestens ab montag soll man nur noch
eine person treffen die nicht aus dem
eigenen haushalt kommt das geht bis
mindestens ende januar neue
beschränkungen führen zu neuen problemen
da sind sich viele eltern einig denn die
verlängerung des shutdown seinen schulen
und kitas bis zum monatsende stellt
viele vor betreuungsproblem nach den
neuen beschlüssen gewährt der bund pro
elternteil zehn zusätzliche tage kinder
kinderkrankengeld für alleinerziehende
sind es 20 tage
das soll auch dann gelten wenn kinder
wegen kita oder schulschließungen zu
hause betreut werden müssen
nicola albrecht berichtet aus
brandenburg 7 uhr morgens bei familien
noack in michendorf sie nennen es den
neuen alltagswahnsinn noch meistern sie
ihn mit geduld mutter anne ist bei der
gemeinde angestellt home office für sie
nicht möglich
für die maßnahmen hat sie verständnis
dennoch ist sie sehr enttäuscht dass
ihre kinder nun wieder über wochen zu
hause betreut und geschult werden müssen
als ich meint wir brauchen eine
verlässliche bildungsorganisationen wo
ich mir denke jahres wissen wir seit
märz letzten jahres
da sind jetzt zehn monate dazwischen
eine stunde früher als sonst wird sie
ins büro die gewinnt sie am nachmittag
matthias noack ist selbstständig
jongliert nun zwischen den aufgaben von
sohn moritz und seinen e-mails die sorge
beides nicht hundertprozentig zu machen
immer im nacken moritz schule bietet
weder online unterricht noch anderen
austauschen ob er das richtig machen das
richtig erklärt haben ob dies das dann
verstehen leistungskontrollen die
politik beunruhigt das ebenfalls
verantwortung sollen die schulen
übernehmen die lehrkräfte sind
aufgefordert zu allen kindern kontakt zu
halten und das wird bei einigen leichter
sein um bei anderen schwieriger
aber gerade das es so wichtig weil wir
sonst die sorge haben dass wir einige
kinder ganz aus den augen verlieren
in brandenburg haben anders als in den
meisten bundesländern immerhin die
abschlussklassen präsenzunterricht die
sorge gilt auch hier den anderen
wissensvermittlung ist nicht das einzige
wir haben hier auch ein sehr hohen
anteil an kompetenzvermittlung und dabei
spielen soziale kompetenzen und große
eine große rolle und in dem bereich sehe
ich ja mögliche defizite und moritz
spielt zwar gerne fußball mit papa
lieber aber wäre er auf dem pausenhof
neue beschränkungen für alle zu wenig
impfstoff um beides geht es in einem zdf
spezial gleich hier im anschluss und in
unserer zdf heute app können sie genau
nachlesen welche regeln in ihrem
bundesland schon jetzt gelten und welche
geplant sind die viel beschworene
freiwilligkeit hat bis heute nicht dazu
geführt dass mehr frauen in
führungspositionen gelangt wären nun
soll es ein gesetz richten
die bundesregierung hat heute eine
mindestquote für frauen in vorständen
von börsennotierten unternehmen
festgelegt konkret bei mehr als drei
mitgliedern muss eine frau mit in den
vorstand kommen
bundesfrauenministerin giffey spricht
von einem meilenstein für mehr frauen in
führungspositionen in die usa dort
entscheidet sich mit den stichwahlen in
georgia wie einfach oder schwierig das
regieren für den gewählten präsidenten
joe biden wird
bislang haben die demokraten um beiden
nämlich nur im repräsentantenhaus die
mehrheit um ihre politik durchzusetzen
fehlen ihnen in der zweiten kammer im
senat noch zustimmen
die könnten die beiden demokraten aus
georgia liefern indes trans amerika
wacht auf nach einer spannenden nacht in
den konservativen südstaat georgia geht
mindestens einer der beiden senatsposten
an einen demokraten den pastor die
wähler in georgia sind aufgestanden und
sie senden eine klare botschaft nach
washington
dies ist die demokratie des volkes
doch werden stimmen gezählt doch auch
der zweite kandidat der demokraten
erklärt sich bereits zum sieger verloren
haben die republikaner verantwortlich
dafür wohl auch präsident trance
rhetorik vom wahlbetrug damit hätte joe
biden die mehrheit im senat in
washington und könnte seine politik
durchsetzen
zu lange ist so dringend benötigte hilfe
für die menschen aufgehalten worden von
den republikanern und trance
das wird sich nun ändern das
wahlergebnis der präsidentschaftswahl
will der kongress heute offiziell
ratifizieren
doch es werden proteste erwartet von
trump anhängern aus beiden kammern
proteste seiner anhänger auch draußen in
washington sie wollen trumps niederlage
nicht akzeptieren
wir wollen dass er im amt bleibt
gerechtigkeit und dass der diebstahl von
stimmen aufhört von ihm werden sie
angefeuert erneut spricht rang von
wahlbetrug ohne belege zu liefern
wir alle hier wollen nicht dass unser
wahlsieg von den radikalen linken
demokraten gestohlen wird das tun sie
wir aber werden nie aufgeben usa ruft
die menge die ratifizierung des
wahlsiegs von joe biden wird zu einem
tag des protests in und außerhalb des
kongresses erinnerte wissen in
washington dennoch sieht es ja recht gut
aus für die demokraten dort oder wie
schätzen sie das wahlergebnis in georgia
ein ja es sieht alles nach einem
doppelsieg in georgia aus denn die
stimmen die noch ausgezählt werden die
liegen in wahlkreisen die eigentlich als
hochburgen der demokraten gelten also es
wird mit höchster wahrscheinlichkeit
zwei neue senatoren der demokraten aus
georgia geben dazu zum ersten mal oder
dabei zum ersten mal in der geschichte
ein schwarzer senator aus diesem
bundesstaat das wird dafür sorgen dass
hier im kongress hinter uns künftig im
senat 50 zu 50 abgestimmt werden könnte
beide seiten haben dann gleich viele
stimmen aber die vize-präsidentin
camilla harris könnte in ihrem
gewissermaßen nebenjob als präsidentin
des senats dann immer die entscheidende
51 stimme für die demokraten liefern und
das ist eine gestaltungsmehrheit für joe
biden und
aber wie wir gerade gehört haben sind
trump und etliche republikaner mit ihm
weiter nicht bereit demokratische
ergebnisse anzuerkennen oder ja das ist
so es konnte hierzu dramatischen
ereignissen kommen
wir stehen hier jahren capitole sind
hier einige tausend demonstranten auf
gezogen darunter auch mehrere hundert
milizionäre sie warten auf das was im
kongress passiert viel zu präsident mike
peng das hat sich jetzt vor wenigen
minuten von donald trump bei der sitzung
distanziert er hat ganz klar gesagt er
habe keine rechtlichen möglichkeiten die
wahlergebnisse aus den einzelnen
bundesstaaten nicht anzuerkennen
donald trump hat gerade angekündigt dass
er möglicherweise die pennsylvania
avenue hinunter marschieren will
vielleicht müsst ihr hin zum kongress
und dem kongress selber werden
abgeordnete der republikanischen partei
einige jedenfalls versuchen die stimmen
für einzelne bundesstaaten nicht zu
ratifizieren
das könnte das ganze verfahren bis in
die nacht möglicherweise auch noch bis
morgen früh hinauszögert es wird am
endergebnis nichts ändern
joe biden wird zum präsident beglaubigt
werden aufregende zeiten vielen dank mrt
wissen
wikileaks-gründer julian assange muss
vorerst im gefängnis bleiben
ein gericht in london lehnte einen
antrag ab ihnen auf kaution freizulassen
die begründung fluchtgefahr
am montag hatte die richterin
entschieden dass der 49 jährige aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht an die
usa ausgeliefert wird
dort droht assange jahrzehntelanger haft
die amerikanische justiz wirft ihm vor
geheimes material von us
militäreinsätzen veröffentlicht zu haben
und fordert weiter die auslieferung
hongkong erlebt gerade die größte
festnahmewelle seit das umstrittene
sicherheitsgesetz in kraft getreten ist
die polizei nahm mehr als 50 mitglieder
der demokratiebewegung fest
begründung sie seien verdächtig in das
verbrechen eines umsturzes oder der
einmischung verwickelt zu sein
die deutsche regierung
kritisierte die festnahmen als
besorgniserregend stefanie schöne baum
morgens früh gegen 6 uhr 30 steht die
polizei vor der tür
doping war politiker der pro
demokratischen opposition in hongkong
er wird festgenommen weil er seinen job
als politiker machte und damit gegen das
sogenannte nationale sicherheitsgesetz
verstieß bei seiner festnahme ruft er
noch hongkonger gebt nicht auf 53
politiker und pro demokratische
aktivisten werden festgenommen
massen durchsuchungen in medienhäusern
sogar ein us-amerikanischer rechtsanwalt
wird abgeführt
wir stehen für demokratie und
menschenrechte in hongkong
sie alle seien verdächtig einen umsturz
der regierung geplant zu haben weil sie
im sommer vor wahlen für den besten pro
demokratischen kandidaten organisierten
das nennt hongkong subversiv und illegal
die festnahmen sind eine klare
machtdemonstration chinas und eine
nachricht an die welt
niemand hat das recht die regierung in
hongkong und in peking zu kritisieren
und wer es trotzdem macht der landet
eben im gefängnis egal wie groß die
kritik dafür auch aus dem ausland sein
mag
sie sind übrig geblieben eine pizza
weniger mutiger die es noch wagen das
letzte bisschen freiheit in hongkong
einzufordern wissend dass auch sie
morgen festgenommen werden können
die fdp macht sich bereit für ein
spannendes politisches jahr gleich sechs
landtage und den bundestag so ein 2021
neu gewählt werden
parteichef lindner will die fdp aus
ihrem langen umfrage-tief heraus führen
wir wollen mitregieren sagte er und
definiert beim traditionellen
dreikönigstreffen der liberalen
ambitionierte ziele
das treffen findet diesmal digital statt
senders
seit 1866 treffen sich die liberalen
immer am dreikönigstag so wie dieses
jahr war es noch nie
die zuschauerränge leer die reden aus
dem stuttgarter opernhaus per livestream
im jahr der bundestagswahl bei der die
fdp zurück in die regierung will
wir sind bereit zur übernahme von
verantwortung für unser land
mehr noch wir haben lust auf gestaltung
die gesamte partei bemüht optimismus zu
verbreiten nach einem jahr in dem die
fdp durch die wahl kemmerich zum
zwischenzeitlichen ministerpräsidenten
in thüringen mit afd stimmen manchen
kredit einbüßte in dem die derzeitigen
regierungsparteien corona bedingt viel
aufmerksamkeit bekommen haben umfragen
sehen die fdp momentan zwischen fünf und
acht prozent
wir werden andere themen bekommen
beispielsweise die beseitigung der
wirtschaftlichen schäden das
wiederhochfahren des landes sicherung
unseres wohlstands die lösungsideen
klassische fdp ansätze mehr
digitalisierung weniger bürokratie und
weniger steuern
fraglich allerdings ob die fdp für eine
regierungsmehrheit überhaupt benötigt
wird
neben der bundestagswahl stehen auch
gleich sechs landtagswahlen an
die ersten im märz in baden württemberg
und rheinland pfalz das ziel auch hier
regierungsverantwortung
wir kämpfen wir haben die letzte
legislatur vieles in rheinland-pfalz
moderner gemacht innovativer gemacht wir
haben eine gute regierungsbilanz der
wahlkampf hier wieder wird wohl vor
allem digital stattfinden müssen das
dreikönigstreffen
als vorgeschmack ja und wir sind beim
sport und norbert und beim finale der
vierschanzentournee in bischofshofen und
da hat es der oberstdorfer karl geiger
doch tatsächlich noch geschafft in der
gesamtwertung den zweiten platz zu
erkämpfen
tolle leistung der sieger der 69 chancen
tournee kommt wie im vorjahr aus polen
und heißt diesmal kabels doch der pole
heute unerreicht für tiger der es am
ende doch noch mal allen bewiesen hat
vor allem sich selbst
geiger zurück in der erfolgspur mit zwei
sprüngen die im platz drei in der
tageswertung bringen und weil die
konkurrenz fehler macht noch an zwei im
gesamtklassement
also ich kann einfach das war ein
gelungener abschluss gratulation an
camille kam es doch besser des tages und
bester der vierschanzentournee seit
heute zum insgesamt dritten mal
linus strasser sieht ganz überraschend
beim slalom weltcup in zagreb ein nahezu
perfekter zweiter lauf bringt dem 27
jährigen münchner den ersten weltcupsieg
in einem spezialslalom tränen erfüllter
moment beim 28 jährigen münchner nach
seinem grössten karriere erfolg im ihre
emotionen sind unglaublich nach einer
oberschenkel verletzung im sommer fehlte
vor weihnachten noch das selbstvertrauen
heute dann von satz 8 nach dem ersten
lauf die attacke auf einer bei
plusgraden schon arg ramponierten piste
in seiner bestzeit die keiner der
nachfolgenden mehr unterbieten konnte
wenn man es am meisten will wenn man so
sehr will dann passiert meistens nicht
und wenn man es passieren lässt dann
passiert
hinter linus strasser landeten die
höchst reicher feller und schwarz auf
den plätzen zwei und drei und die
deutschen handballer siegen im em
qualifikationsspiel gegen österreich mit
36 zu 27 starke leistung der neu
formierten dhb auswahl kurz vor der wm
bester torschütze masse schiller mit elf
treffern der den leicht angeschlagenen
kapitän uwe gensheimer vertrat garanten
für den sieg aber auch die torhüter wolf
und bitter am sonntag geht's nochmal
gegen österreich noch ein sieg und das
em ticket wäre geboten
ja danke zum schluss haben wir noch die
lottozahlen lauten folgendermaßen 14 21
32 37 38 44 und die superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
winterliche aussichten gleich von katja
horneffer besonders im norden bleibt es
klappt auf den straßen im süden zeigt
sich morgen auch mal kurz die sonne
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse marietta slomka erwartet sie
um 21 45 zum heute-journal und wir sind
morgen wieder für sie da punkt 7
einen schönen abend wünschen wer jazz
[Musik]
meine damen und herren es waren zwei
unterschiedliche teams die uns heute den
schnee gebracht haben dass eine tief hat
inzwischen tschechien erreicht und das
andere die ostsee
das ostsee tief zieht bis morgen abend
weiter richtung südwesten und wird
deswegen dem nordwesten deutschlands
morgen weitere schnee und schneeregen
fälle bringen es schneit heute nacht
aber auch noch am alpenrand zum teil
sogar richtig kräftig sie sollten sich
also auf gefährlich glatte straßen und
gehwege einstellen das gilt auch in
norddeutschland auch dort schneit und
schnee regnet es weiter
die temperaturen in der nacht sinken auf
plus 2 bis minus 7 grad
es ist also überall kalt genug für
glätte und das bleibt auch morgen über
tag so bei temperaturen um den
gefrierpunkt da fällt ja meist am
meisten schnee und der fällt morgen
besonders in norddeutschland es bleibt
also glatt auf den straßen besonders
hier im westlichen niedersachsen und
auch in nordrhein-westfalen in sachsen
ist es etwas freundlicher und südlich
des mains haben sie doch eine reelle
chance auch mal die sonne zu sehen und
am besten klappt das mit dem
sonnenschein wohl am alpenrand
vormittags kann es in passau noch mal
einen letzten schneeschauer geben am
freitag beschränken sich die schnee- und
regenfälle auf die gebiete an der ostsee
und die mittelgebirge danach geht es
ruhiger und winterlich weiter schönen
abend noch